can you unpack what some of the stuff
you saw I mean you know sometimes I sit
and I let's just I'm going through my
newsfeed and I'll see a mother or father
beating a six-month-old kid I'm like why
is this thing here it's got 52 million
views I'm like this what's the purpose
of leaving this on or you'll see some
bizarre videos that make zero sense for
them to be on but they have those things
up there what did you see and I can only
imagine as a user what that makes me
feel when I walk away what are some of
the things you saw
I saw a lot the best way to explain it
is if you've been to many of these sites
I know some of them are not around
anymore but there were sites such as
um best gore chaotic with a K there was
the Live Leaks
um there were many other sites that I
could think of like hard candy
and you would have these uh videos
mainly of the just these horrific acts
that could range from Child pedophilia
to putting fireworks in a dog's mouth
and then them setting it on fire
to um fathers making their daughters
have sex with pigs and then
stabbing the pig while the daughter was
having sex with the pig
I saw those types of videos day by day a
lot of these had to deal with bestiality
abuse against animals
I also specialized in during the summer
it was in China the dog eating Festival
so the Facebook allowed these different
types of videos and photos up there of
people that were cooking skinning eating
dogs alive
because Facebook said that due to the
cultural differences it would be the
equivalent of us having pictures of cows
or chickens so they allowed people to
basically just mutilate dogs on live
stream through video through photos for
the sake of this dog food festival that
they have in China every summer so you
see that video you see the dog eating
Festival in China what else was there so
so far it's sexual exploitation animal
any other you've seen also killing
you've seen like live Shooting what else
are some of the things you guys are
seeing uh there were plenty of live
shootings in fact a lot of them came
from the United States having to do
between gang wars people that would um
just have their cell phones out in the
middle of a shootout there would also be
a lot of content from the Middle East of
people that were stoning pedophiles to
death or people that were basically just
beating their kids until they were black
and blue on the face and their eyes were
popping out of their head
a lot of the content that had to do
within the Middle East usually had to
dealt with beating women and children or
stoning people that they perceived as
doing a wrongdoing there was in fact
this one video that I was working with
content wise and it was a person going
to put a gun in another man's mouth and
then pulled the trigger and you could
visibly see the innards going through
the back of his skull
and I actioned it to delete it and there
was another person that like checks the
moderators checks the checkers so to
speak and this person made the claim
that what we saw was not actually the
visible energy going out but bullet
fragments
and I made the argument that it's
clearly white these are skull fragments
coming out of the back of their head
they're not silver they're not bullet
holes
and this person actually said that I was
wrong and that video was allowed to stay
on there because of that so
a lot of a lot more of the content had
to deal with uh sexual exploitation a
lot of it dealt with children that were
online and they were basically being
groomed by pedophiles to come meet them
in person
oh there was also an incident with organ
harvesting videos so a lot of these
children in other countries
were basically being ripped apart alive
and they were having the organs taken
out while they were screaming and I
remember how bad it was that day because
everybody had to come into the main area
and calm everybody down there were like
people that were throwing up on the
floor like people that were just
screaming and crying wait these are your
co-workers who are throwing up on the
floor yes and
um I remember one of our team leads was
telling us how we were going to be
getting more graphic content
specifically because Facebook couldn't
keep up with the amount that they were
getting so they were telling us that
like the floodgates were opening so we
were just going to be dealing with
graphic content all the time in my
department
so I got two questions let me go to the
one uh first uh you know when
cops and cops are known for having a
very high divorce rate because the life
of a cop is not the most glamorous life
you know all we see is you know what
they're doing we see it on TV good cops
bad cops all this stuff but they have a
very high divorce rate the life sucks
from what many of my friends talk to me
about a person who's a divorce attorney
you're not going to be able to have uh
you're constantly talking about divorces
and if you're married you're going to
come home and all you're thinking about
is you're probably next because your
entire life is about divorces I was
being recruited to be a special forces
at the 18 Delta fifth group at Fort
Campbell Kentucky and they asked me to
go interview with other 18 deltas
and the guy was telling me he says you
ever planning on getting married and
falling in love I said of course he says
don't ever become Special Forces because
you can't you're psychologically going
to be off I'm like I'm sorry this is
your psychological going to be out
that's going to mess with you that was
one interview then I went to the next
guy then the next guy the next guy
some jobs you take they're gonna mess
with you but this is different there's a
difference between you watching you know
certain videos and certain articles
versus seeing this how are you guys
psychologically affected by this when
you're doing this eight hours a day and
you're going home how are you handling
that how's it affecting you
uh I was actually doing this 10 hours a
day uh specifically because they needed
extra hands on deck for the extra two
hours to do this
so I was there always a bit longer than
most other people were specifically
because of the department I worked in
um just talking about the mental health
of the people that I worked with it was
not good within the building
so there were people that were smearing
feces on the bathroom walls there were
people that were defecating in the sinks
and the urinals there were people that
would just be like
smoking drinking in the middle of the
day in their cars during their break
period
there was always talk about people using
the break room for sexual activities
there was always people that were
bringing in all sorts of illegal
substances to take while they were doing
this stuff
just the mental health of my co-workers
was not well because of all of this
uh specifically going through we were
supposed to have a counselor there some
mental health therapist to help
I was only able to see this person once
and it wasn't even the actual one that
worked there it was someone that was
just filling in and I remember he flat
out told me I don't know how I can help
you guys
because he did not know what to do he
did not see the type of content we were
seeing
and he just flat out said I'm filling in
but I don't know how to help you guys
because all of this was new to him as
well and I never met the actual person
that was supposed to be on board with us
every day
and a lot of my co-workers I spoke with
never met this person either
I'm not even sure if this person really
existed or maybe this person was only
there like a few hours a few days so I
have no real confirmation on this person
ever actually helping somebody through a
tough time they've had there so if you
like this little short clip from an
interview I did click over you to watch
the entire interview and please don't
forget to subscribe to the channel take
care everybody bye
[Music]